these images have shocked the world
Venezuelan soldiers preventing
much-needed aid from coming into the
country from neighboring Colombia
but while the aid is kept out a steady
stream of Venezuelans pour into the
Colombian city of Kakuta over the nearby
Seamon Boulevard bridge leaving behind
hyperinflation and empty supermarket
shelves these people exit by an official
border crossing many others have not
been able to obtain a passport and are
forced to leave the country via
smuggling routes cutting through the dry
riverbed known as truckies they are
controlled by criminal gangs who extract
a heavy transit fee from the migrants
it's a price they are willing to pay in
the hope of finding work and a better
life in Colombia I'm going to Medellin
because I have family there and we will
work because there is nothing in
Venezuela the more you wait the worse
the situation in Venezuela will get
since neighboring countries demand that
Venezuelans show a passport more and
more people are using the trucker's to
leave with no money for any transport
they often have to walk for hundreds of
miles it's a business opportunity for
shoemaker dominga Montilla who also fled
across the border
sometimes the shoes of the people that
come by are really damaged they're
falling apart with the sole missing I
saw visions back together for anyone
that needs it I charge five thousand
pesos for every shoe that I repair even
regular commuters have taken to the
truckies which snake through the
riverbeds only metres from the bridge
Carlos querétaro carries goods across
the border to sell in Venezuela on the
black market customs officers have
clamped down on the cross-border trade
forcing Carlos off the road to continue
his work forties don't let us work we
have no other choice
to use the trojan Carlos only earns four
euros a day shuttling goods across the
border while for many the trucker's are
an escape route for him they are a
lifeline